it's harry but this is this is a very  dirty harry this one  this is not this is not a happy harry  this is a dirty harry  this is one of those are you looking at  me son this is this is this is oh my god  the accelerated harry attack yeah  oh my god this is actually the first  time we've ever caught a move like this  yeah  we see it happen on other boards or we  see one c3 one d3 the boring stuff  h4 now and  what is that white pawn doing out on h4  it makes no sense it doesn't fight for  the center it doesn't improve the  development of the white pieces  i are you having it simon  i don't really know if i'm loving it or  not but it's i've played this in blitz  obviously and it's a load of rubbish  it's a terrible  we have the harry attack against the  queen's gambit